[Music]
did you guys know the IRS wants you to
claim your illicit cash [ __ ] the IRS
what is it what solicit cash money that
you that you have illegal money yeah why
would I be legal money what you do
you're like hey if you made money
selling drugs or selling [ __ ] on the
side
can you please report that to the or
does that also include well of course
like when you're a server and someone
tips you in cash you're supposed to your
support sir okay so that doesn't count
illicit is like making money through
illegal means like hey Tim I'll sell you
my pills right now and then I'm supposed
to report that to the IRS
that's funny hey you know that robbery
you did in 2019 can you please report
that to your taxes yeah on line 21 on
Form 1040a it does say for you to like
itemize it yes your income from your
self-employment activity you're like
that was $500 when I robbed a liquor
store yes so what is happening is that
criminals are paying taxes on illegal
gains because they're trying to avoid
getting double penalized so once for
doing the legal crime and then again for
not reporting upon went to jail tax
evasion yes can I always take that and
then now rat on them for that thing
again so it's only dumb criminals that
are doing it no so these are criminals
that they know that they're being
investigated then they're like oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna claim it oh that can't get
caught it like twice okay cuz okay cuz
I'll see you saying cuz if it's on a big
level like that and you're making these
like you're buying cars and [ __ ] there's
so much yeah where does money coming
from and then you're gonna get audited
yeah yeah well then you need to so where
you get your money from Barclays got to
do this [ __ ] for sure yeah there's this
guy named Tom Hughes he was caught
multiple times deal
money from his clients concei was an
accountant and so he says that he knew
that that money was taxable and that he
knew that he was getting caught so he
had to or he didn't want to face federal
tax charges so he ended up paying taxes
on his illegal gains in 1999 and 2001
and again in 2004 after he stole them
from another client and then after a
nine nine month period stint that's when
he swore that he was reformed and so now
he has an anti fraud can that
consultation agency called hire a thief
Wow yeah so now he helps other people to
not only Lord TurboTax maybe TurboTax
doesn't have the line items for like
robbery burglary a different form you
can't call anybody be like yo I'm a hit
man like I got paid like yeah he
specializes in crime so he's like hey
are you an art thief or are you an
assassin and we're not jewels yeah
Julie's yeah see that's the beauty of
the illegal money is that you don't have
to necessarily say what the crime was
you'd be like let's say you're a hit man
you got paid 10 racks to shoot somebody
what's 10 racks 10 racks is $10,000 Iraq
you that's cute sounded way more rack is
a thousand thousand so you got like 10
racks 10 G's to kill somebody
what are jeez oh thank you Iraq is also
a country in the Middle East that we
invaded also a set of breasteses all
right hundred G's a stack is also
equivalent to Iraq are you ready no
that's
I've heard of stacks or bands as well
ten bands Millions
a milli no but some would also say an
mo3 m9 three mil I was just saying since
it's a it's a crime he already got away
with you don't have to say it I got 10
G's for killing somebody you'd be like I
got 10 G's for you know just delivering
packages
wasn't supposed to yeah but what if you
want to tax write-off on the car you
rented the hotel you stayed in for the
assassination you're like I had to take
this flight to the Bahamas that's what
my target was that's true so if you're
doing your target taxes right you should
be able to get it right off for all the
business expense yeah you're right up
should be a lot of racks have to write
down every LSA activity I don't know or
so you just bubble ELISA in you're right
wherever you one thing is that this hire
a thief guy is saying that you should if
you're gonna be doing this because
you're avoiding like you know double
time do crime the right way you should
be hiring a tax attorney tax attorney
not any old accountant so you need to
have a tax attorney to help you oh do
all this like a legit lawyer lawyer yeah
like a lawyer for taxes did they pass
the bar and they got the CPA license
that's double like double agents did you
watch that movie the accountant he's got
a gun yeah it's a signatu it's a big big
there's a department in the IRS with the
guy I had like a counting with guns like
they do math and they [ __ ] shoot what
the accountant wasn't that Ben Affleck
movie with the worst title of all time
is that what the movie was about yeah I
thought it was just a count and I was a
hit man that's why they shouldn't call
it the accountant yeah it's not good
time no there's a department in the IRS
that's actually like armed and [ __ ] did
you know there's a USDA agents - shut
the [ __ ] up they got guns and they're
like imma protect the milk yeah yeah I
was looking up different special agents
because they deal with it they do with
drugs right in pharmacies I don't know
maybe illegal horses or whatever but
there's like like there's a special
agents for USDA and like all to break up
like illegal slaughterhouses in shape
yeah every single like almost like even
like the US forests whatever there's
special agents for all of those two
parts please that book is taking prime
select no they're like oh you are beef
that's what it is dude what's an illegal
horse is that a horse that comes in the
u.s. from Mexico illegally just selling
horse meat
I think audit maybe I like his theory
better no but you know you know what the
agents say when they're there but doing
a horse bust they go hey hey oh you want
beef don't you say neigh neigh I don't
get it because horses say man you know
the noise horses maybe okay horse is
also gone there's our cows really horses
don't do that shame mr. and does poor
some horse would never do that
[Laughter]
damn catches our [ __ ] they are mad dude
I know I just looked at um cuz we're
gonna escrow right now for a house and I
looked at how property taxes are gonna
be and I'm like property taxes are the
worst [ __ ] but you can deduct them
that's what's cool too the tax
deductible but [ __ ] man like still get
paid though you do when I when I bought
the house I get year and a half ago like
couple years ago whatever I got the
option to either put my property tax as
part of my monthly payment or just or
that's what we did to it smart oh yeah
do that so you don't get it [ __ ]
hurts cuz I was like now I'm not gonna
do that uh let's keep my mortgage
payment how it is and then I'll just
handle the property tax when it gets
that [ __ ] I'm like this doesn't even
make sense brah I go in there make the
payments I'm like oh but when you pay it
monthly that's not bad because you don't
you're not even painted chances yes just
this smaller son yeah I'm trying to
change it because that [ __ ] that's all
adult II do combine that [ __ ] with HOA
mix a man drink yes what did he grab so
much beer at our house now
owners insurance you know this [ __ ] I
was just currently shopping for that
stuff and I'm like are you on a fault
line did you see all that [ __ ] too you
guys make fun of my mud hut dreams I'm
not gonna have bills to pay but you
never hospital those two people you need
to hire someone to continuously patch up
your hotel you dress himself I don't
like this we did more mud yeah don't
know but it's Joe you're gonna warming
electricity you have no look you yeah
we're gonna [ __ ] ill Wi-Fi and plumbing
that's it in the main house dude why
like oh don't go in there that's the
[ __ ] house should've thought of that
all right I'm gonna get a multi-unit and
I'm gonna live in one of the closets how
about that yeah what's a mud condo oh
yeah you in have you seen those [ __ ]
oh man what is that it's like The Hobbit
or something oh that's cool to the the
houses in the hills but in Turkey they
got this whole like city made out of
[ __ ] mud or something I don't know
what oh wait the one in the clips yeah
it's like a I don't think anyone
actually lives there but I want to live
in there
yeah but why I seen that too for this
that one's more modern cuz they build it
out like an actual house yeah I'm gonna
say those houses that are being made by
3d printers that are being made like
ours and [ __ ] yeah so it's like there's
like the smaller ones yeah but it's just
like a little like a big ol 3d printer
just puts you in the Semana whatever and
they just and I think it's just the
outside and they put in all the little
you don't have those weird 3d printer
lines on it
I know yeah we're running out no but
it's pretty it's ringing uh-huh
it's running out of ink oh my house is
gonna light over here
but now yeah they just then they can
build houses within like hours Jews
gonna be like Star Trek's man when
you're gonna get to walk up to the thing
and you're gonna go yo give me like a
[ __ ] lasagna and it'll just make the
lasagna
that's Jetsons dude no that's [ __ ]
Star Trek Geo you don't even know this
yet Geo
what about Jetsons bro
kid Jetsons couldn't even dream of that
kind of [ __ ] oh my god intro the Jetsons
yeah
yeah they [ __ ] have a little pill and
then it makes a whole meal yeah it's not
a [ __ ] pill Gian for you're talking
to our thing in the wall I feel stupid
where do they come out of hey it's
called replicator comes out it comes out
of air it just goes like this it makes
it with all the [ __ ] moms call a
replicator motive yeah Geo it's not this
[ __ ] super pill it sucks with you I'd
rather have that making it out of air
yeah I wouldn't need because think about
it what's everything made out if it's
not I made our molecules rounds and [ __ ]
so what if you could if you had a
sequencer that could create the exact
kind of mass let's breathe somebody
gotta feel what I eat and then we're not
that we like then that's when the
humanity can finally wait how did they
get killed somebody gotta kill what I
eat that kill the animal he doesn't want
to eat like I made synthetic meat it
makes it out of those same molecules and
atoms and so it's the same exact [ __ ]
yeah it's like cloning the meat molecule
you're one of those people that like the
impossible burgers no the one from Umami
Burger isn't bad actually it kind of it
tastes like when I first had the
impossible burger from umami it was kind
of like I was like this could be real
meat it could be but it's not ready to
squirrel me that's nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]